home so we've begun in London a golden
era of council house building again
since I've become mayor we've now
started building numbers of council
homes last in this 1970s more than 23
000 so of the 300 000 new homes the
government the new government the labor
government wants to be building each
year a significant proportion in our
city has got to be Council homes homes
supported by housing associations but
also of course private sector terms as
well numbers
so in London uh what I'd like to see is
roughly speaking
a half at least of all new homes being
market value and the other half a
combination of council homes
we pay a London living rent based on
average earnings a third of average
earnings and homes that assured
ownership part by part rental for all
the aspiration for homeowners who can't
afford the deposit you need in London of
almost 150 Grand
with another we've done it in seven
years we've met the target the
government said so people who are
looking absolutely listen We've Only
Just Begun
at affordable house building Revolution
it takes some time because many councils
over the last 40 years have forgotten
how to build Council house building they
will hollowed out in London for every
six Council homes sold off only one was
uh rebuilt and I'm sure you've met as I
have many uh londoners who've got a
degree they've got a job moved back to
Mom and Dad's home or many rely upon
Bank of mum and dad so in London the
good news is the government said it's a
Target when I first became a mayor that
was before the complexities of brexit
led to labor shortages and Michelle
shortages that was before the pandemic
before interest rates and inflation is
going up we've got the target though and
we've done it by working closely with
councils developers and associations but
also by having planning policies in
place that allow us to meet the needs of
londoners talk to me what's going on
about you Les
um ultra low emission Zone you want to
extend it you are going to extend it by
August to cover the whole of greater
London dining Street are considering
whether you've exceeded your powers well
no Dynasty have confirmed that I've got
the powers to do this what I'm trying to
do
is to tackle three issues one is climate
change
two is the air pollution problem and
three is congestion and the good news is
when we first introduced the ultra
emission Zone that you mentioned in
central London within two years we
managed to reduce the toxicity the
poison in the air by almost 50 percent
we expanded it to Inner London up to the
north circular and South circular a
further Improvement of 21 but here's the
problem
there are 5 million people living in
outer London and in outer London is
where there's the largest numbers of
people with respiratory issues asthma
and so forth and the largest number of
deaths I think clean air shouldn't be a
privilege it should be a human right and
so by expanding the ultra emission Zone
we'll make sure that all londoners
breathe cleaner not just those in the
center you say dining Street are
agreeing with you um that's debatable
um Hillingdon Council the leader of
Huntington Council says the benefit of
Euless is negligible or nil so sometimes
you don't agree don't agree with me they
say with the powers to do so it's really
important to clarify so there are four
conservative councils uh in London and
one outside London which makes five who
are who are opposing these policies and
indeed taking me to call
uh you know that's the choice that
they've made we'll have to wait and see
what the Court decides I'm quite clear I
can be in that generation of politicians
uh that deny this that the noise is a
problem
or delays taken action or I can be in
that generation of politicians that's a
doer taking action I want to be
appalling that takes action it's like if
I was here in 2004 five six we'd be
talking about whether we should ban
smoking in public spaces many people
opposed Banning smoking in public places
you and I both remember Roy Castle a
trumpet player who got cancer lung
cancer by playing the trumpet in working
Men's Clubs well there are modern
versions of londoners who are dying
because of their own London Ella kissy
Deborah a nine-year-old child uh was
just one example okay as I said the
leader of Hillingdon Council saying it's
negligible or nil he's wrong he's
denying the science the science is quite
clear look from the chief medical
officer to expose like Oldman Street to
experts at the Children's evening
hospital to the wealth Health
Organization to Imperial College all
agree we've got an air pollution crisis
that requires uh action in London around
four thousand premature deaths linked
with air quality every year tens of
thousand around the country children
have stunted lungs forever because of
toxic adults with a whole host of health
issues from asthma to cancer dementia
heart disease all linked with air
quality what's happening is this okay
just like 20 30 years ago politicians
would often talk about denying climate
change they can't anymore so they're
delay in action and the same goes with
air pollution there is a problem I'm
determined to fix it okay let's let's
talk about those um councils uh five of
them as I said all conservative I should
point that out and they've all joined
together with this judicial review
um they say that the consultation
process was not properly conducted and
you didn't carry out a cost benefit
analysis of the plan well those
arguments were rejected by the high
court of the five arguments put forward
three were rejected two have been given
permission to be heard and there's a
court case in July I don't want to
prejudge the court case I'm quite clear
I'm quite clear all processes uh were
followed but also accepting a democracy
it's right and proper people should be
allowed to challenge my decisions in
this case in the high court
um I think that same right to challenge
decisions should be available to others
like Asylum Seekers and refugees as well
by the way there we go considered
scrapping and replacing with a pay as
you drive scheme no I'm quite clear to
us Works look Euless Works in relation
to the plutar pays uh principle when I
first announced his policy in 2017 the
number of vehicles compliant in our
great city was only about 39 the rest of
the vehicles more than 60 were polluting
uh Vehicles now we have within Central
and in London more than 94 of vehicles
are compliant so that are polluting as
much and in outer London more than 9 out
of 10 are compliant but also we've seen
a massive Improvement in the air in our
city this policy works so I'm just
disappointed for Party politics reasons
the conservative councils you mentioned
are using taxpays money not for more
libraries or to improve air quality but
to pay lawyers to challenge me in the
high court two other questions if I may
one of them is about a story that's in
lots of the papers today particularly
the front page of the Daily Mail I
noticed sakias starma they say is in in
quotes are trying to rig the next
election by allowing European um people
from European countries to vote in this
country if they live here well let's
let's do the issue of direct selection
what we do know is this government
is suppressing voter turnout the next
election by requiring everybody
to have a photo ID in relation to the
next election what the layer parties
looking into documentation that says
they haven't got it photo ID you just
have photo ID in relation to phone in
the next general election we do know by
the way uh that in London uh roughly
speaking 2.5 million London has done
over driving license and half a million
don't have a passport so that's a real
problem in relation to the next election
which this government has passed the
number you can then go on to apply for
certain documentation to if you haven't
got those documents you can get other
documents but we know from the local
elections just recently held very few
people actually did do that which led to
a real real concerns so that's the
government story suppressing the vote
using lessons from the Republicans what
leopard is looking into and I fully
support this is those EU citizens who
have secured status subtle status been
here more than five years are paying
taxes who are eligible to vote by the
way in local election and neural
elections just like the our Irish
counterparts who can vote her our
citizens and Commonwealth citizens we
should enable those who have been there
for more than five years have secured
status to be active citizens I want
everyone in our country not to be
passive consumers but active citizens
and that includes our EU friends and
neighbors
um and finally what are you doing about
what the Met we're up to um during the
coronation look can I can answer that
question firstly if I said oh I'll ask a
question directly but the context is the
police today by and large remarkable job
more than 11 500 police office worked
really hard I met many of them in the
days leading up two and on the day of
the coronation by and large a really
good operation more than 300 uh you know
foreign leaders in our country and
looked after safely there are concerns
which I share in relation to a small
number of protesters uh six members of
Republic anti-monachist movement and
also three volunteers at Westminster
Council I think in a democracy it's
right and proper that the police should
be challenged when you think they've
heard the commissioner has agreed to be
fully transparent responding to the
concerns that have been raised and that
I think is important because people have
concerns and they should be addressed
okay so you you spoke to the
commissioner you said you had concerns
what did you say well samaka's in a very
openly explained the police and
operations so people can understand the
challenges the police have had he's
agreed to have a review an operational
review and I'll be working with him to
make as much of that public as possible
so the public understand
some of these challenges but also I
think it's important where you get
things wrong you put your hand up and
say you get things wrong and I think
it's right that the police did apologize
to those uh members of Republic who were
arrested we now know based upon
imperfect uh intelligence the police
will never get everything right all the
time but we need to have a culture where
they're more open more or transparent
and I'm sure this commissioner will you
know do a big job in getting people
across the country including in London
having more confidence now please so you
support preemptive arrests well no
they're not no I don't I support the
police being challenged in relation to
when they use their powers I think the
police in their own words got it wrong
in relation to the six members of a
republic but the police officers were
relying on imperfect intelligence in
real time with a lot of pressures on the
uh police there's a there's a parallel
universe sort of slide indoor scenario
where the police don't act on
intelligence and those people do have
things which can be used to cause huge
disruption endanger Public Safety and be
a criminal offense but the police on
this occasion have put their hands up
they've you know apologized to those
protesters who were arrested there are
other questions we've got in relation to
the use of the new Pals the new public
order act the new section two uh when it
comes to locking on when it comes to
going equipped to a lock on these are
powers the police have been given by
Parliament the police bill of police
without fear or favor but it's right
that we should ask questions after an
event because it's important that we
learn all the time